"The Green Knight" is a fresh take on the classic
hero's journey. Like with so many heroic odysseys,
"The Green Knight" is many things,
but, above all else it is this:
extremely and incontrovertibly weird.
There are magic spells, ghosts, giants,
spiritual foxes, and nightmarish fates. What in
this supernatural world is real, and what is the
imagining of our hero Sir Gawain? The answer to
that isn't immediately or easily illuminated.
Similarly, even the way the story
ends seems almost shrouded in mystery.
Not to worry, though -- we can work
the strands of this strange tapestry
together until they weave a pattern that
at least makes some semblance of sense.
"The Green Knight" is the tale of a young man
named Gawain, who just so happens to be the son
of Morgan le Fay, and, thus, the nephew of
King Arthur and Queen Guinevere.
"The GreenKnight" never uses these names — other than
Gawain's — but as the tale is based on the
14th century romantic epic "Sir Gawain and the
Green Knight," we can make some inferences.
At the start of our tale, Gawain, played by Dev
Patel, leads a free, uneventful life full of wine,
women, and song. He seems to spend more nights
in the bed of one woman in particular, Essel,
played by Alicia Vikander, who dreams of
being his lady in the courtly royal sense.
But it's not until Christmas Day that the die is
cast. King Arthur invites Gawain to sit with him
and Guinevere while they discuss the possibility
that Gawain might someday have knightly tales totell.
Gawain's mother summons the titular Green
Knight, who challenges all knights in the hall
to cut him with his own axe, and, in exchange,
have the same wound visited upon them by theGreen Knight in a year's time.
"I'll meet him."
"You understand this challenge?"
"I do."
Gawain accepts the challenge and, thinking he's
solved the situation, chops the Green Knight's
head clean off. But the Green Knight is no mere
mortal, so he picks up his own head and rides
away, laughing all the way in the knowledge
that he will kill Gawain in a year's time.
This moment is so important because it tells us
what this incarnation of Gawain is all about.
There are many fictional accounts of Gawain which
portray him at times as noble and at other times
as graceless, callow, and utterly dishonorable.
"The Green Knight" portrays Gawain as a man
manipulated too easily by his own ambition. This
Gawain wants to have songs sung of his gallantry
and he wants people to see him as honorable.
However, from the outset, he seems more
interested in perception and power than he does
with the actual responsibilities of knighthood.
When Gawain arrives, one year later, at the
Green Chapel as the Green Knight demanded,
axe in hand, hypothetically ready to be
decapitated, there exists a duality of
desire within him -- one which wishes to die a
hero, and another which wishes to live and becomeking.
The end of "The Green Knight" is about
understanding the consequences of both choices.
The end of "The Green Knight" is split into two
sections: what could happen and what does happen.
In each, Gawain has in his possession a magic
belt that is meant to protect him from any blow.
And yet at first, we see Gawain distrust
his own magic and flee -- reflecting the
cowardice we see in him throughout the story.
During his quest, Gawain is defeated by three
lowly thieves, we watch him accidentally drug
himself with hallucinogenic mushrooms, and we
see him betray the word he gives to a lord, played
by Joel Edgerton, as he keeps the lord's property
and gives himself over sexually to the lord's
wife, who is also played by Alicia Vikander.
Again and again, Gawain denies his own knighthood
when that title would get him into trouble.
And yet when Gawain returns home after running
away and forsaking his word to the Green Knight
as well, he still accepts knighthood
from Arthur as though he deserves it.
Not only that, but Gawain also takes a son
he has with Essel, leaving her forsaken,
marries into royal blood, and becomes king -- a
terrible king. Gawain's subjects despise him and,
while his magic belt protects him, he watches
his son die and his kingdom fall to ruin.
In the end, Gawain dies a failure to his name
and his people with neither honor nor nobility.
And then suddenly, we're back in the Green Chapel
as though nothing ever happened -- Gawain's
future a mere glimpse of things to come.
In the face of that horrifying destiny,
Gawain removes his protective belt and
allows the Green Knight to lop off his head.
We get one earlier glimpse of this side of Gawain
when he helps the ghost of Winifred find her own
head at the bottom of a lake. In that moment,
Gawain helps Winifred find peace. In the end,
"The Green Knight" is about how it's better for
Gawain to die an honorable person than to live
a long, miserable life, a stranger to oneself,
and a victim of one's own most craven nature.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.